[Music]
[Music]
we talk about exciting developments and
discrepancy and application
Thanks so disclaimer I'm not really
planning this to be a an overview
tutorial discrepancy theory I'd try to
focus on things that are more relevant
approximation algorithms into rounding
specific let people settle in a bit
oh no just go okay good so I'll talk
about some applications of discrepancies
here in if you don't know that is our
you'll see a little bit of it to
approximation algorithms so here is the
plan for the talk I'll start with some
basics like definitions sort of a first
glimpse of what discrepancy is and what
it has to do with approximation and and
with rounding then to make things a bit
more concrete I'll talk about one
particular application to designing an
approximation algorithm for the pink
packing problem and then I'll talk about
some bounce on discrepancy and some
algorithms for finding low discrepancy
colorings whatever that is and then oh
I'm permitting a knife that I think I'll
have time I'll talk about actually the
problem of approximating discrepancy
itself so this is the plan I haven't I
don't have too many slides and I try not
to pack them too much so there is time
for questions talk to me if you don't
understand anything I can fill in
details if you ask for it
and if we have time and we should okay
so I'll start with something very basic
that I probably do not need to introduce
to anyone here but I just wanted to make
sure we are on the same page so now
start with this basic paradigm for
designing approximation algorithms one
of maybe the most versatile four general
methods to design an approximation
algorithm so what is this so we take our
hard combinatorial optimization problem
we formulate it as an integer program
and this is one example it's not like
without loss of generality but it's you
know one reasonable example of an
integer program so say this is a
maximization problem now we'd like to
solve this this is say something that's
equivalent probably to our combinatorial
maximization problem but the problem is
that we have these integrity constraints
so this is not in general solvable
efficiently so we relax it in the usual
way we replace the integral constraint
say if we want a binary solution now
instead we ask for a solution that could
be fractional and has bad as between 0 &
1
now this is a linear program so this we
know how to solve efficiently or many
people here do for sure all right so we
solve this with our favorite interior
point algorithm or something and now
when we solve this we get an optimal X
for this problem right but this probably
unless we unless something really
special happened this probably is not a
valid solution to the original problem
ok in particular X is not integral
probably so we'd like to now somehow fix
X that is rounded to an integral
solution without losing too much so that
we actually have a solution to the
problem we're trying to solve and this
is the most mysterious part of this
whole thing right this is where you need
to be creative somehow so you'd like to
design a rounding algorithm that doesn't
lose too much in terms of this objective
function okay so very kind of abstract
and basic so in this talk I'll focus
about the last step rounding I'll talk
about some math that some algorithms
that can maybe help in designing good
rounding algorithms
stop me anytime with your questions I
don't expect on this first slide but
good so what do you want from a rounding
in general let me use this notation I'll
in general use Z for most of the top
four integral solutions so let's say we
round next to Z this R of X is just the
output of some rounding algorithm so one
thing we want is that these feasible for
the original problem another thing we
want is that the objective function is Z
is not too much smaller if you have a
maximization problem for example then
the objective function at X usually so
usually here we compare with the optimal
LP solution and this would mean we have
an approximation factor alpha so for
this talk and for the application of
discrepancy 2 to this problem of
designing a good rounding algorithm
we'll look at a two-step approach okay
so we'll break the problem of designing
this good rounding algorithm that
satisfies these conditions or something
like these conditioners into two steps
so it's a first step well first just try
to round X to a Z so that we just
approximately preserve the constraints
of the problem so remember the
constraints were that easy
the ithe coordinate of AZ this is what
this means is less than B I maybe will
allow some slight D and D here is going
to stand for discrepancy okay and then
in a second phase will try to fix these
violated because these may be slightly
violated constraints we try to do that
without changing the objective I do too
much right so we we break down this into
two problems because the first problem
is exactly something which we can try to
do with this purpose e and you see that
in the course of the talk okay the
second part remains problem dependent
and there you still need to be somehow
creative and look at the structure of
your problem so here for the second step
I cannot say anything general but I'll
say some general things for the first
step ok so this is the plan
so this brings me to linear discrepancy
so the discrepancy is one way to
formalize this first step of taking a
fractional maybe LP solution or some
fractional vector rounding it so that
some linear constraints are not
validated by too much so here's the
problem I have some X think of X pretty
much with the entire well most of my
slides X is some vector in 0 1 to the N
and we want to round it to an integer Z
in the best way possible
so say we use this so we want to
minimize over all Z the maximum that the
ice constraint can be violated and we
take the maximum over all the
constraints okay so here if they can the
absolute value sort of for symmetry this
is definitely an upper bound on how much
we could violate our ice constraint if X
satisfied it to begin with okay and just
to make the notation a little more
compact so this inner thing this inner
maximum which is the infinity norm of a
Z minus a X this clear how this is
related to rounding this is just the
problem of given X what is the best way
to round X in terms of this objective
and this objective gives an upper bound
on how much we can violate constraints
when we do that just every don't want to
lose people on the first five slights
good and if you worried that this
doesn't include any information about
the objective function we can always
include the objective being objectified
being less than something is one of the
linear constraints here so see the
objective function that it can be one of
the rows of this matrix okay so we can
include some information about objective
function here okay and now being a
discrepancy just asks what is the worst
case of this overall fraction of X ok so
this is what we will call this is our
we'll deal with like three different
notice and discrepancy so I hope this is
if if you get lost at some point ask me
stop me and ask me the first one is
linear discrepancy this so this is the
maximum
overall fractional X of the maximum
error we can introduce by rounding X if
we round it in the best way possible
okay so for every X we round X in the
best way possible
we look at how much we violated our
initial values and we take the maximum
over all X so this is sort of some
worst-case estimate if I only give you a
and I don't know anything about X what
is the worst that can happen if I always
round in the best way possible this make
sense questions to this point okay okay
so this is linear discrepancy and now
I'll talk about a different kind of
discrepancy and maybe this will seem
sort of animal on unmotivated at first
put in a slide I think it will be it
will be clear what the connection is
okay so these are the other two an
office and discrepancy and that's going
to be it I'm not going to introduce any
more so first we just have basic
discrepancy I mean just discrepancy of a
matrix and this is just the minimum over
plus minus 1x of the infinity norm of AX
okay this maybe should have I could have
motivated this from another direction
with these problems of colouring
hypergraphs this makes sense in some
other realm but maybe for now just take
this as the definition so this is
discrepancy right or discrepancy is just
the maximum discrepancy over all sub
matrices okay
they are the definition screen so here
is one reason why this might may it all
be connected to anything about solving
linear programs and rounding and
fractional integer solutions so this is
a an old characterization famous by
wheeler Korea I can quite pronounce that
name I'm sorry from 62 which is that a
matrix a with entries minus 1 0 1 he's
totally unimodular
if and only if it has hereditary
discrepancy 1 ok so anyone not familiar
with what totally unimodular means
it's for the one person sorry this says
that all sub makes all square sub-matrix
deserve a have determinate either plus 1
minus 1 or 0 but the reason this is
interesting is that if you have an LP
and the constraint matrix is totally
unique modular and say the the B vector
is also integral then the optimal
solution are integral as well or there
are there is always an optimal so the
vertices are integral of the feasible
region ok so this is one reason why
expect this to have anything to do with
solving linear programs and optimization
and this motivated a later theorem which
will be the one that's important for us
which is nice result by lava Spenser
investor Gumby which has the linear
discrepancy is always at most a
hereditary discrepancy so might seem a
little strange why I'm introducing this
seemingly more complicated thing to deal
with this which was maybe more natural
but it treats in terms of techniques I'm
not aware of many techniques to directly
talk about this guy but we have some
tools and you'll see them to talk about
this guy ok so I'm not quite sure why
that is but at least right now we seem
to be able to say more about this it's
sort of a more robust quantity in some
sense that's maybe the only thing I
could say so the next thing I want to do
is give a sketch of a proof of this
theorem it's an easy proof good
time alright so how do we prove this
louis pasteur western coffee theorem
first easy observation this is just free
scaling so first I want to say that
actual discrepancy is saying something
about a rounding problem in particular
it says something about rounding the all
one's vector so this e when i say e here
I mean don't want vector okay I'll use
this maybe a couple of times during the
talk okay so this was that the
definition of discrepancy and just by
rescaling you see this is half this
which is the error for rounding the the
all-caps vector in the best way right so
this is the error for rounding the all
halfs vector this clear do we need to
see a proof of that this is just kind of
rescaling from plus 1 a minus 1/2 plus
1/2 minus 1/2 and shifting everything by
1 so I don't think you need to proof
read good so this is an easy observation
this immediately says that we can round
1/2 integral vectors with cost at most
1/2 the curator is referencing this okay
ended up a little cryptic so what I mean
by that is okay so what's 1/2 integral
vector I please define that as a vector
whose coordinates are for these purposes
let's say 0 1/2 or 1 okay so you just if
you want to round that you just ignore
the zeros and ones that was already
rounded and you around the halves when
you around the 1/2 so you just use this
okay so the error you get from rounding
is just at most the discrepancy on the
sub matrix corresponding to coordinates
that have 1/2 values okay so that's why
you get the curator discrepancy here you
need to know something about the
discrepancy of sub matrices already here
as well and the point of the proof is
that rounding 1/2 integral vectors is
all you need to be able to do because if
I give you an arbitrary vector
say I have these three-dimensional guy X
1 X 2 X 3 I can write in binary so
assume this is X 1 X 2 X 3 written in
binary you can always assume that these
guys are rational I mean if we get them
out of an algorithm they're going to be
rational anyways and we just start
rounding basically from the back from
the least significant bit so this is how
the proof goes so ok so what do we do we
look at the least significant bit that
we have written we look at the ones ok
and we just try to round the ones to
either up or down right and we do that
by taking a minimum discrepancy so when
you talk about discrepancy for
historical reasons like because of some
connection I'm going to call these guys
X a coloring oh if you get ok hope it's
not confusing ok so we just get the best
discrepancy coloring for the coordinates
of this vector they correspond to the
ones in the least significant bit and we
just round those so if we get a +1 we
round them up if we get a -1 we round
them down ok so this is just this
observation here all right so let's say
we do that we rounded this least
significant 1 bit here say up and we do
need to do a carry right so we do need
to kind of mean free round up we have to
make sure that we're doing the
arithmetic correctly then after we do
the carries we can look at the next
slightly more significant bit we look at
the ones we round them up or down and we
just keep doing that right until we look
at the most significant bit that's after
the radix point we round those and then
we're done
ok so what is the error from all this
rounding from our analyze it from from
the back from the end of the algorithm
back okay so for rounding the most
significant bit this is like the half
integral case right so here we got half
the curator discrepancy for the next
guys to get 1/4 the territory
discrepancy right because here we're
rounding things that look like 1/4
either to 1/2 or to 0 and we go like
this if we add all of these up we get 1
ok 1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8 and so on is at
most one that show we strictly
the one if we have a rational X at least
this is this is the proof what do we
need to make this proof into an
algorithm what we just need to be able
we need some sort of Oracle let's say
that for any sub matrix of a gives us a
low discrepancy X for that sub matrix
okay so and then this is y whoop if we
if we want to apply this we'll have to
do to look at algorithms that find these
low discrepancy colorings so questions
okay so next I want to give you one
example how to use this viewpoint to
prove on old result bogged in packing so
I mentioned in your results but I'll
actually show you how to prove an alt
result which in a way still the best
that we know how to prove so you see
what I mean
so far it's been packing very classical
problem input is a bunch of items
specified by sizes sizes are numbers
between 0 and 1 in the goal the
objective is to pack these items into
the fewest number of basis of size 1 ok
here is some picture of items in pairs
it's prompt here
been packing okay important problem I'm
not surveying there's a ton of working
been packing okay I'm not remotely
trying to give everything about being
packing at all I just give the result
that are most relevant to what I'm going
to say so first of all to mentioned this
seminal paper by karma Korean carp it's
so what they proved is that you can pack
your items into opt so efficiently into
AAPIs order of log squared up many bits
okay so opt is the actual optimal number
of bins that you need to use you can't
quite get that it's an np-hard problem
but you can get a plus log squared opt
and if all your items are at least
constant size then in fact their
algorithm gives you a plus order of log
of megabase of course the constant here
also reflects in the constant here right
so as you make this constant small or
this constant gets bigger okay and the
most the other thing I want to mention
is the most recent result is by Paul
Burke and rod Foss and they basically
prove this bound maybe up two different
constant but for arbitrary input so
without the restriction for how big the
item sizes can be okay so in some sense
you can see the result is showing us
that this is kind of the hard core of
the problem and this is the best what we
know right now for bin packing there's a
conjecture that you can actually aa plus
a constant number of bins I think even
aa plus one is possible as far as we
know so the best coordinates I think is
between two and three
this is the best MP MP harness but this
problem is do you need two things for
three minutes so plus one it's possible
and there's a particular LP relaxation
we should see in a minute which i think
is also conjectured to give you that
value so if you round up I mean for all
instances that we've we know if you
solve the LP and round it up and add one
this is an upper bound on the optimum as
far as we know so and I think it's at
least some people conjecture that maybe
this is always sure alright so how are
these results proved if it's the ones I
mentioned all use this LP relaxation
which is do to do more in Gomory I'm
sorry I didn't include the reference
this is an example of what's called
configuration LP okay so this is a
configuration LP for the bin packing
problem
so before I explain it detects a little
bit to explain so before I explain it
like me first tell you what's a feasible
feasible pattern if this what I call a
feasible pattern so remember have n
items and a pattern is a binary
n-dimensional vector right so think of
this as an indicator vector we call this
feasible if this summation P is is at
most 1 in other words our P is an
indicator vector of some subset of the
items and it's one feasible way to pack
up in now this out pieces
minimize the sum of excise so that px is
at least 1 so an X is non-negative so
the problem really that this LP relaxes
is find the smallest number of feasible
patterns that cover all the bins sorry
all the items will cover all the items
find the smallest number of feasible
feasible patterns that cover all the
items and clearly the integral problem
here is equivalent to bin packing and
this is a relaxation you should maybe
wonder how you solve this LP because the
number of feasible patterns in general
can be super polynomial will be super
polynomial but there are things you can
do there actually there's more than one
solution to this problem maybe the
simplest is to use the multiplicative
voice algorithm and post-games more
starters framework you can also use
ellipsoid to stop the duel so you can
solve the separation problem
approximately over the door here so the
separation problem ends up being an
instance of knapsack so you have an F
Peters so that's another way anyways
there ways to solve this LP it's not
trivial because you have possibly an
exponential number of variables but
there ways to solve it usually you're
fine with some approximation factor so
then multiplicative voice may be the
things
all right so how do we use it this LP -
so how do we round right I'm going to
show a rounding which is not exactly
I mean it's similar but it's not exactly
the original rounding of Karmarkar
because I want to show you a rounding it
usage discrepancy and this comes from
this very nice paper by precise and
brand Pelagia rod boss from 2011 which
brought out this connection -
discrepancy so there's some piece right
there but I won't okay good so what do
we do we solve our LP some way we get
our optimal or nearly optimal X and now
we're just going to take so I've written
a here so a from is sub matrix of this
matrix P which corresponds to the
support of X okay so remember X the hole
X can have exponentially many variables
or quarter units so we don't want to
write all of it we just ignore the zeros
and we take the corresponding sub matrix
of P okay so those are only the patterns
that correspond to the support and again
remember these patterns give you a way
to pack items in a bin so I've labeled
the rows by items or items sizes rather
remember I don't know if I said this so
I'm ordering their size the item size is
from the largest to the smallest
okay and now if you take this matrix a -
probably a X this tells you so the ice
core unit of this ax tells you how many
slots we have in these patterns at least
fractionally in which which are of size
exactly si okay so this gives us how
many slots we have of size exactly si in
these patterns now of course we want
this to be at least one for every I want
at least one available slot for every
item of every size good so the first
thing you do is to apply just our
discrepancy rounding to this matrix that
turns out not to be the right thing to
do because it it makes it hard to then
fix so you already might lose here too
much and it may be hard to then fix this
infeasible solution and make it feasible
again make it possible to pack all the
items into this and what you're not
using if you do this
is the fact that you can put smaller
items into slots for bigger items okay
so you should somehow use that so here's
one way that maybe it's not apparent at
first it that's what is happening but
here's one way to use that so I change
the matrix a so what I did here is I
replace the I throw of this matrix with
the sum of the first I rose in the
original matrix okay so really what this
is doing is that I change the meaning of
this matrix vector product ax so now in
the I'd coordinate of ax what they have
is the number of slots that are
available fractionally that have sighs
at least si so this is the number of
slots into which item I fits and here
I'm using the fact that I fits into
bigger slots as well so now to this I
apply the discrepancy coloring oh sorry
one more thing I also introduced um you
know I also as an action before it's
good to add the objective function
vector is one more row of the matrix
just to make sure that when we do the
rounding we don't introduce to many more
patterns too many more pins okay and now
to this I apply my discrepancy rounding
I don't know why I called matrix B to be
this combined modified matrix I could
have called I still anyways we we use
our discrepancy rounding here and we get
some ax here which maybe doesn't satisfy
the constraints so the constraints say
that we want at least I items of size at
least si instead I get this - some D and
D here is the hereditary discrepancy
good good and actually I won't quite
finish the proof so from here I'm
claiming is not a very hard exercise to
see that if you have this property that
for the for all I for the I biggest
items you have at least I available
slots minus D okay if you have that for
a why it's a nice exercise to show that
now if you just throw D more bins in
okay you can pack all the items it's a
nice exercise using house theorem
huelga timing wise okay yeah I think I
shouldn't go into it good so now the
question is what is d right the
approximation we get here is plus D and
maybe another plus D from here from the
objective function vector so with most
plus 2 D but what is the what is the
creative discrepancy of this matrix
first what is what is special about this
matrix what can we say about it and if
you stare at it pretty much the only
thing you can say about it is two things
so first its monotone down every every
column okay so the numbers increased on
every call or it at least don't decrease
and second all the entries are bounded
by K if you would have the property that
at most K items with per bin in other
words let's say all the all the item
sizes are at least 1 over k plus 1 ok
good good all right
and now another may be not such an easy
exercise but I'll show you some tools
how to bound discrepancy and a little
bit and and those can show you that
these matrices you can use those to show
that these matrices have this rapid yuan
leak on the order of K log n I think
that's an upper bound so this
immediately implies plus order K ok a
plus order log n approximation for bin
packing when all items have constant
size but they're sort of standard tricks
that lets you argue that you only have
to care about the case where n is at
most opt ok so in fact you get plus
order log opt approximation this
approach gives you that this was already
shown by from a credit card but the way
I'm showing it to you is more like this
paper of isin brand for walking route
boss and if you want now to handle all
possible item sizes using the remark and
card tricks you lose a lot of log opt
but if you go to back and Thomases paper
you see how you can use this purpose in
a more sophisticated way and use an
additional operation called gluing to
reduce the general case to this special
case without losing anything extra or at
least not
more than order of log off together okay
this is the best result we know so far
and I'll just mention one result we had
with offering Iman and Atlanta new one
in 2012 for vaguely speaking we show
that no rounding algorithm that only
uses the patterns in the support of a
optimal basic feasible solution can do
better than this order of log opt even
for this special case of all item sizes
have at most constant size actually even
even for the special case where at most
three items fit in a bin you're allowed
to do this trick where you take a small
so the only thing you're allowed to do
basically is use these patterns in the
support and also put smaller items into
slots for bigger items that's the kind
of rounding you're a lot to do and if
that's all you do and that's what that's
you you can modify the chromatic art
algorithms only do that then you're
stuck with your slog oft no it's just
it's it's unconditional but it restricts
the kind of rounding you can do as in I
can give you a problem instance which is
actually very easy to solve if you just
look at it but I can give you problem
instance which if you solve the LP
at least there are basic feasible
solutions which using this rounding
you're doing the wrong thing like this
sort of this class of roundings it's a
funny result of it
yeah but yes this also uses discrepancy
yeah sure what accuses a discrepancy
lower bound
questions here so this is one my one
example to give you something concrete
how you can use this crap and see to
give a interesting rounding for like an
interesting problem very much trying to
use this stuff to motivate people to
look at what else you can do with these
techniques by the way I think there's
not too many there more examples than
been packing but not too many
and again techniques doesn't necessarily
mean like black box results you can also
just really mean the techniques and I'm
going to now start showing you some of
the techniques okay so now in the next
part of we are in the next part of the
talk where I'll give you some basic
bounds and also some basic algorithms so
start first with this concept of partial
colorings okay so now in this part of
the talk we have some theorems which
need some parsing so we'll go over them
and again ask me questions if something
is not clear so here is a version of the
thing that's usually called a partial
coloring lemma it's very nice and so I
call it a theorem so this is the version
due to lava to Mecca I mean this is a
strengthening and an efficient version
of all the things but this version is
due to love it in Mecca so there it's
it's a strengthening of previous results
by back and Spencer and here is how it
goes so by the way I'm always assuming I
should say maybe so I try to be
consistent notation so for me a is
always a and by an M by n matrix right
good so here's what this says
I call it partial call you should think
of it as partial rounding so we have a
fractional vector X we have some numbers
think of them as sort of error bounds
lambda 1 to lambda M and I have this
technical condition on the lambdas I
want that the sum of these Exponential's
is at most n over 2 okay and I will
interpret this in a little bit and then
the theorem says that we can efficiently
compute Z which again is possibly
fractional such that these bounds are
satisfied right so for every I the ice
core unit of AC minus ax is most lambda
times this is the L 2 norm Euclidean
norm of the I throw of the matrix a and
so so
this is trivial we can just take Z to be
equal to X but then the the thing that's
interesting is that actually we can
guarantee that a constant fraction of
the coordinates of Z are okay
I said integral what I mean is plus
minus one okay so here integral means
plus minus one I'm sorry not zero okay
right so maybe we didn't fully round X
okay but we partially rounded it we at
least got the cost of fraction of the
coordinates 2 plus a minus 1 again you
can rescale to make this 0 1 all right
and of course usually the way you use
this is you then recurse on the
remaining fraction of coordinates until
you're done you'll be done in like log
and iterations so just to give you some
intuition for this first compare this
with the first or second thing you would
do which is just randomly round X every
coordinate of X independently right just
with the right exploit just randomly
round X 2 plus or minus 1 with the right
probabilities so that the expectation of
the rounded vector of the rounded you
know number is equal to actually 2 X I
right so the usual way to do a
randomized rounding and if you use a
turn of bow you see that to get this
condition by randomized rounding you
need something like this right it looks
very much like this the less important
thing is that the constant in the
exponent is different but that kind of
doesn't matter for these applications
the more important thing is that here I
allow this sum to go up 2 and over 2 and
here I need it to be less than 1 right
because with the randomize rounding what
this is this is an upper bound on the
probability so we want this to be
strictly less than 1 okay so in in some
settings this is important this buys you
a lot and to give like one kind of
extreme example of when this buys you a
lot if you have a fairly small number of
sets of constraints sorry of constraints
if M is less than half n then actually
you can set all the lambdas to be 0 and
this is satisfied this is clearly not
satisfied of course and I get the these
things actually exist at that these are
exactly equal to 0 in this case right so
I have no error
and I have that a constant fraction of
the coordinates an integral so this is
the kind of thing usually you get from a
setting up an LP writing and getting a
basic feasible solution this is powerful
enough to get that you can also get you
what you get from a randomized rounding
so it's sort of a way to interpolate
between these two already powerful
techniques
questions
and notice here this Z can be computed
efficiently so the proof is an algorithm
and here I want to show you what this
algorithm looks like so let me to do
some notation first from the rest of for
the rest of taco use Q for the
plus/minus 1 cube and I'll write K for
the set of those Y's which satisfy our
discrepancy constraints right so while
we're Z must lie here and also much like
here this is what we asked for Z right
is that it's in the cube and it
satisfies these constraints okay so with
the algorithm is is first let's take the
intersection of those two sets so those
are going to be like the height the
bounding hyperplanes have or some of
them of k and i tried this is supposed
to be cutting off the corner of the cube
i trihard ok so it's not it's not yeah I
hope it makes sense and then well yeah
the message just does you you start with
X which is in the intersection of those
two guys of course and now you just do
Brown your motion inside this
intersection of those two guys thank you
and you do brown your motion until you
hit a facet and then you stick to the
facets okay so with the brown your
motion when I say Brown your motion
think very tiny Gaussian steps ok so
another tiny Gaussian step I think at
this point I get bored and I fast
forward and then once you put on your
motion hits the facet you stick to this
facet and you don't leave it anymore and
you keep going and basically every time
you hit the face you stick to this face
and Q here the vertex and then there's
nothing more you can do so then your
stop and you stop with the vertex u
output that verdict that's that's your Z
ok so this is the algorithm ok so what
is the success condition when has it
succeeded by construction this is in
case so the discrepancy constraints
actually by constructs are set by
construction satisfied what we need to
know is that Z has a lot of plus minus 1
coordinates and that corresponds to just
looking at the tight constraints in Z
the factors that define Z and you're
asking that at least and over ten of
these and tight constraints should come
from Q
right this is what this means this is
what it means for Z to have at least n
over 10 plus -1 coordinates here and why
do you expect something like this to be
true the intuition is that we chose the
condition on K this explanation or
something so that the the facets of K
are guaranteed to be at least on average
much further from X than the facets of Q
so as you're doing this Brownian motion
you're expecting that much more often
you're hitting facets of Q then you're
hitting facets of K this is all say it's
actually the analyses not hard this is
basically what's going on but this clear
good maybe I should say yeah I think I
should say there's there's some later
work by Thomas and also by Mohit Singh
and Rennie all done where they gave a
different algorithm should I just I
didn't put it outside but I really want
to say what the algorithm is because
it's it's so simple so there's different
algorithm is kind of you look at the
same Q same K again you look at the
intersection of Q and K but instead of
just Brownian motion
you just pick a random unit vector and
you solve the linear program with this Q
intersect K is the feasible region you
solve that linear program and you you
output an optimal solution for that in
your program so you just solve the new
program over this in a random direction
okay and that you can show satisfies the
same kind just the same conditions I
hope what you don't get aget right okay
so there you analysis is a bit harder
but the algorithm ended up really really
simple this is one set of algorithms and
now I want to talk about a different
sort of upper bound and this is a bit
more geometric it's very powerful
only recently we've been able to do this
algorithmically so I want to very very
recently so I want to be able to tell
you something about it it will also be
useful for approximate inherit or
discrepancy which is should be the last
part of my talk but so first a
definition so use this notation for a K
norm okay so this is just a norm again
this is defined on so a more n
dimensional space and I don't have
anything to right I'm sorry so this is a
norm defined on in the space in which
like X and K lives so here K is some
convex set convex body actually so it's
a closed convex set with non-empty
interior and this is the norm with unit
ball K so this is very simple what is
all this is it's just the smallest
scaling of K so that X ends up inside of
it okay so K some convex set X is a
vector and this K norm of X is the
smallest scaling of K so that X is
inside of it and here's a picture this
is K you need to scale it this much so
it extends up inside this clear it's
kind of a general definition one all
right so with this notation this
powerful result by Banasik says the
following so if you have a matrix whose
columns are not too long in particular
have euclidean norm at most one and if K
is a convex body then there exist a path
minus one X vector X so that the K norm
of AX is it more say ten times the
expected K norm of a standard Gaussian
okay this is even for people who've seen
this this is not the way usually you see
this theorem
it's the one that was convenient for me
now
let me interpret this a little bit so
for example the thing that people
usually have seen is
a the he also put the condition that
this cake has go siient measure so the
probability the Gaussian ends up inside
K is at least half
okay so K is large then this would mean
that this is a constant in this case all
this is saying is that ax is in a
constant scaling of K so this says that
basically if K is big enough ax ends up
in like 20 times K so we're statement
maybe a little bit when you see it first
okay so it says something about being
able to balance and we remove this kind
of being able to balance the column
survey it's important that the columns
are they are not too big of a are not
too big and that K is big enough okay so
if you have those two conditions then
you can balance out the columns of a by
giving the plus minus one signs
carefully so that you end up inside 10
times K right we'll see how to use this
to show to say something about
discrepancy first I want to give an
equivalent theorem to this one
equivalent in the sense that this
implies this by a short argument and
this implies that as well so they're
both true okay so this is it something
we proved with Daniel deduce salad
garlic and chakra love it okay so from
last year so that this is equivalent to
the following statement which doesn't
have convex bodies anymore
it says the following maybe it's a
little easier actually to understand if
a matrix if a is a matrix with that
satisfy the same condition okay
then there exists a distribution on plus
minus 1 vectors and dimensional vectors
so that a times X when X is sample from
this distribution is order 1 sub
Gaussian and here is what this means
okay so all the ones the Gaussian just
means sub Gaussian in every direction so
if I take any unit vector theta and I
look at ax dot product with theta this
is a random variable we'd say constant
variance and the tails drop like
Gaussian tails okay so the property to
be
tea out in the theta direction is it
most e to the minus two square it over
constant and C is a constant it depends
on nothing okay ten or twenty not sure
good and so what we showed is that this
is true in a particularly this implies
this and this implies that as well okay
so they're kind of equivalent and
actually the direction from here to here
is intuitive you need a theorem but it's
intuitive if I sample X from you okay
then X then ax is sub Gaussian so
somehow acts at least as well as a
Gaussian so you expected the the
expectation of AX of the K norm of X is
at most some constant times the
expectation of a Gaussian okay this is
not trivial okay because sub Gaussian
only says something about one
one-dimensional marginals but it turns
out to be true it's implied by the major
icing measures theorem it's a fact yes
[Music]
we're not non Euclidean norms yeah so
this is I'm sorry
yes educator I mean I mean I oh yes I do
not know yeah I'm not sure you might get
some different distribution well in the
first theorem Gaussian seems to play
in the first theorem if me going back
maybe a little bit in the first year I'm
if if all your assumed is this I'm not
sure if you can get this same conclusion
with with any other with any other
restriction on the norms of the columns
of a so I know theorems that say if a
has columns without one norm one then
you can find an X so that the Infinity
norm of AX is at most two but this is
special to infinity norm I don't know
what to say what I can say about general
K and it's similar so it's the
relationship is not very hard actually
you have like as long as you can prove
something like this with some condition
on a you like to be able to prove this
with the same condition on a it's it's
more general than this actually this is
yeah it's more general than matrices and
matrix vector products it's kind of
something about existence of sub
Gaussian distributions versus finding
points in large enough bodies where
large enough is with respect to Gaussian
measure it's just a very general
equivalence between those two things
does this answer a question
all right good so one thing I meant to
say is one reason we prove this is
because this seems easier to turn into
an algorithm now if you want to turn
this into an algorithm you just need to
find a Mew that you can sample from
efficiently and once you can sample from
it efficiently for general statements
about sub Gaussian distributions this
immediately means that if I sample this
if this is X from this distribution then
ax in a the K'naan reaction in in
expectation is what I want it to be and
maybe I can do this several times and
take the best ax okay so if you can do
this algorithmically you immediately do
this algorithmically without doing
anything more and after some effort
finally maybe but it appeared on archive
in a few weeks ago Nikhil Basu Daniel do
douche shots of gorrik and chakra love
it were able to actually do this they
were able to construct the distribution
mule which we can be samp which can be
sampled efficiently and an excess of
Gaussian under these conditions again
it's a random walk in the cube look at
their paper it's beautiful it's not very
complicated I highly recommend it
I won't describe the algorithm I think a
few more things I want to say okay so I
will not describe the algorithm but it's
not hard to describe actually very nice
I'll just talk about two edge cases okay
just to give you some intuition so one
edge case is when the column severe or
so normal it's easy to see that the best
thing you should do I think it's take X
to be just a uniformly random vector
from plus minus one and you can just use
a Chernoff bound to show you this that
ax is sub Gaussian on the other hand if
all the columns of a uniformly random is
really not the best thing you can do you
should really shouldn't do that you
should somehow carefully choose X so
that it balances out the columns so that
they cancel each other so you should
force cancellations and somehow they're
proof
manages to divorce it both at the same
time in a very nice way okay so of
course what you're going to usually get
is something in between and then you
also have to do something in between and
there there is a way to do it I can tell
you more offline and they can tell you
more offline there I think they're all
all except Shahar here ok so how you
actually apply this thing what does this
have to do with discrepancy yeah this
this theorem was proved I think it is to
some extent to address the famous open
problem in discrepancy here which is the
commas problem the Commish conjectured
that for any matrix again a without two
norm of the columns at most one there
exists an X plus minus one so that's
under the infinity norm of these guys
constant and here constant is
independent again of the dimensions away
so absolute constant still quite open
nice problem you I encourage you to try
the best result we know is immediately
implied by this theorem of bonus check
and it says that you can achieve order
of square root of log M can M is the
dimension of the column survey so our
matrix is M by n and given the way I did
the theorem the proof is just if you
look at the theorem all you need to
understand is the expected infinity norm
of a Gaussian and you just do a journal
bound and a Union bound and a little
computation you see this order of square
root of log M it's also widely known
fact it's actually theta of this right
this is the right bound and just apply
the theorem ok this is how you get this
bound this is the best we know and now
we can also do it algorithmically due to
this work that I just mentioned all
right and now I want to also talk a bit
about in the remaining minutes a bit
about the complexity of computing
discrepancy as well and also you know
you in the course of this you see
another application of this commotion of
this Banach theorem
so complexity discrepancy so if you're
going to apply this reppin C to do
something algorithmic I think it kind of
makes sense to try to to see if you can
actually compute discrepancy as well
right you want to be able to know these
roundings if I give you a matrix you can
try to put on your mathematician hat and
like try to prove bounds and a
discrepancy of matrixes of this kind
whatever this kind means or you can hope
that you can just take the matrix and
compute this discrepancy and that's an
upper bound and like what you're
rounding can do right so if you want to
go the second route and compute this
wrapper see also it's you know it's a
nice optimization problem to try to
solve maybe this is motivation enough
then
how hard is this how hard is it to
compute discrepancy and the first result
I'm aware of for these notions of
discrepancy is something we proved with
Moses cherry Coronel Anthony moon we
showed the design be hard to distinguish
between those two extremes for
discrepancy on one hand discrepancy
equal zero is one extreme in the other
extreme is the discrepancy of the matrix
is Italy is on the order of square root
of N and this is for the case where
matrices are 0 1 so have 0 1 entries and
the number of rows is at most a constant
bigger than the number of columns ok and
I'm saying those are two extremes
because ok discrepancy 0 is clearly the
smallest it can be and up to constants
for these kinds of matrices this is the
large the largest the discrepancy can be
this is a famous result by Spencer this
is the 600 deviations to 5:06 because if
this is an N by n matrix the upper bound
is actually at most 6 square root of N
good so in that sense computing
discrepancy is actually really hard
there's nothing you can do and maybe I
can stop but no okay
so I think the what they say is actually
the discrepancy not the right thing you
should compute remember that what we
need for an for an application is
hereditary discrepancy and it turns out
that this is also the discrepancy notion
which is easier computationally
basically because it's more robust in
some sense so this this bulb doesn't
give you enough information for
applications by itself okay and also
it's very hard to compute and sort of
for the same reason it's not robust
enough this is more robust and you can
actually do something with it so there's
at least a couple of papers here but the
best approximation we know is from a
paper I had we cannot old war where we
showed it you can approximately write a
discrepancy up to a log M to the three
halves power and sort of incomparable in
some ongoing work with Daniel the douche
canal again and Nicole Tom Cech
jaegerman which he showed that you here
you can have poly log in the rank of a
as opposed to the dimension okay so this
can be a lot smaller the power of the
log is not quite the same so they're a
bit being comparable but this is nice
for other reasons so I can tell you more
offline and the best part is we know is
that this is a be hard to approximate
curator discrepancy it's a PR to
approximately better than a factor of
two and this is a result of Austrian
hosta and guruswami and there's quite a
bit of a gap so there is another problem
there to work on
and I want to tell you a little bit
about how your approximately something
like your discrepancy so remember
I'll have the definition remember
character discrepancy okay
this is maximum over J subsets of the
columns of discrepancy of AJ okay so
it's some it's a maximum of
exponentially many over exponential many
empty hard problems okay so each of
these is a minimum over an exponential
number of things so it's not an empty
optimization problem so it's not clear
how we can do something like write a
realization for this so the first hard
thing to do is to give interesting upper
bounds on this guy because how do you
upper bound something like this it's
some non traditional relaxation and
here's one that you can get from one
Astrix theorem first I'll do something
that clearly won't work and then I'll
make it a little better and it's going
to work okay so the first thing that
doesn't work he's just apply panache it
blindly
okay our body case just the cube which
gives us the infinity norm and then we
just rescale a I mean panache extreme
two matrices whose columns have
Euclidean norm at most one so because if
this here have to include this other
factor which is the maximum Euclidean
norm of a column of a okay so just by
simple rescaling panache exterior most
so implies this it implies it for when
this is one but you can rescale and then
you get this upper bound because this is
clearly not the right upper bound first
let me say why it's an upper bound for
hereditary discrepancy as opposed to
free discrepancy and the reason is
simple but maybe this is a little subtle
the point is that this the right hand
side is already hereditary right because
this okay so this is some constant and
this is column of a okay and the point
is that if I take some sub matrix this
can only decrease
so this holds for the whole matrix but
in fact immunity calls for all sub
matrices as well however is clearly not
the best like it's not the right bound
if you just have a single column okay if
you right so if you if you just have a
matrix that has one nonzero column then
you pretty much never this is going to
be the right thing good so we'll try to
improve it a little bit so what we
didn't use is the fact that the Banach
theorem holds for any convex body not
just for the cube right so here's a
simple observation which I think is
maybe not obvious though very simple so
what we care about is the Infinity norm
of AX which is the Q norm for of ax just
because the plus/minus 1 cube is the
unit ball the Infinity norm
okay but now we can always apply the
same say invertible linear
transformation thousand you ever have to
build in your boot on the keyboard in
your transformations so we can always
apply the same linear transformation
both to a and to the body Q okay so this
Q norm of AX is equal to the TQ norm of
t ax just because ax being in a scaling
of Q is the same as TX being in a
scaling of TQ if T is invertible
that's all I'm saying it's nothing
complicated but now so this is some
symmetry of the problem we can use this
symmetry and we can improve the upper
bound by taking the minimum of this
overall T and this is our better upper
bound this is what I'll call lambda of a
there it is big
strange complicated thing it's the same
upper bound when instead of using the
cube here I use this right
okay so this lambda way was defined to
be an upper bound curator discrepancy so
that's not surprising the interesting
thing is that if you divide it by body
log it's also lower bound okay and this
needs proof this is the main thing we
proved so I don't have time to you know
give any detail but very very high level
sketch is that it's not obvious at all
but you can formulate lambda way as the
value of some convex program you have to
work to do that and then you can write
the dual so this is a minimization
problem the dual be a maximization and
convex problem again and then you can
then your goal is to convert everything
any feasible solution to the dual to a
lower bound hereditary discrepancy and
here we need some technique to give
lower bounds but those are already
existed so lava Spenser Western Gumby
are already showed some nice volumetric
lower bounds for curative discrepancy
and we use those okay so this is kind of
in the super high-level sketches right
this is a convex program okay so for
people who like convex programming and
connect and like connections between
discrete and continuous this is a funky
convex program but you can dual eyes it
and turn feasible solutions of the door
to lower bounds on the quantity and this
is how you prove this direction okay and
this program can be efficiently solved
and actually you can relax it and even
get an SDP out of it which again if you
look at the form of it it doesn't look
like an SDP at all but okay it's
possible and some open problems we've
been talking all about here a tree
discrepancy what we care about was
linear discrepancy and I said pretty
much nothing except one bounds the other
I've know nothing about the hardness of
lean discrepancy computing and
approximating it
you can take any of those things that we
know about hereditary discrepancy I
don't know what to say about linear
discrepancy directly except there is
this connection between them there is
some conjecture that one is sandwiched
between the other for like matrices that
are 0 1 but that's open as well okay
using discrepancy rounding for more
problems is it more widely applicable so
we have a few examples there's been
packing there's some scheduling problems
as well so there are a few examples but
maybe they're more improve what we know
for bin packing maybe get all one solve
the Commish pro questions so the way the
way I wrote it it's not clear to me
because actually it's very yeah this
this form of it is very new to me
actually this is this ongoing work with
Daniel and Nicole and kunal for a while
I didn't think this is a complex problem
and then we found a way to agree
parameterize it so that it's convex
but this SDP relaxation of it then we
know that this log to the three halves
is basically tight they're examples
where it's tight but for this version
actually I don't know so the person I
showed is actually the one where you can
also show something in terms that's poly
log in the rank
that's one which makes it much more
general actually but other questions
and all the icy peace relaxation of it
but the relaxation is already strong
enough to get you log em to the three
halves but this one can also get you
like log-rank to the 2.5 or something
not realize version which however is a
stranger program and the dole is crazy
yes question I have to think about that
yeah but so I'm in a room full of with
some not to do fraction of people who
know these things so I we should try
here we shall have a question for the LP
of impacting the exist instances in
which rounding is not enough there are
instances where rounding is enough yes
yes so is this the case where if you if
you take the ceiling and then add one
then right so that's better so that's
that's what I'm meant to say it I think
one open problem is you take the LP
value you round it up then add one more
okay and then maybe this is always an
operand for all we know thanks thanks
other questions
[Applause]
[Music]